[MUSIC PLAYING]
SAPTARSHI MUKHERJEE:
I'm Saptarshi Mukherjee.
I lead the product marketing
function for our data analytics
and IoT business areas.
And today we're going
to have a really, really
interesting topic.
We're going to focus on the
total economic impact of moving
data analytics
workloads to cloud.
How do you evaluate
some of the options?
We will be joined
by Mike Leone--
he's a senior analyst from ESG,
Enterprise Strategy Group--
and Sam King who
is an engineering
manager from Nuna Health.
And they're going to share
some of their insights.
So why did we choose
this particular topic?
Google Cloud is a fairly
deep technical conference.
But when we engage with
customers, a lot of them,
one of the common
recurring themes
that we hear from them,
that we have the best
technologies in our
on-premise data centers, or on
cloud x or y.
If we move to Google
Cloud, how is it
going to impact our cost,
our total economic value?
So it's important
for us to understand
that all data warehouses
that are running in the cloud
are not the same.
All Hadoop or Spark
workloads that
could run on different
clouds are not the same.
So how do we essentially
evaluate those options
through some fine
grained parameters
and come up with a
TCO model that's going
to give you a long term value?
So today we're going
to talk about why
economic impact in the cloud,
especially for data analytics,
matters, some of the
key considerations
for evaluating the
economic impact,
and then we will take two
use cases, one moving data
warehouses to the cloud.
And we will talk about moving
data warehouse to BigQuery,
as an example.
And Mike is going to take us
through the economic rationale
and economic modeling for that.
And then we're going
to talk to Sam.
They have actually moved their
on-premise data management
platform to Google Cloud.
What were some of their
decision criteria?
What has been their
experience so far?
And then we're going to
go to the next use case,
talking Hadoop and
Spark movement to cloud,
and how to evaluate the economic
impact for that particular one,
and then come to
some conclusion.
Hopefully it will be a useful
session for all of you.
So with that, I'll first hand
over the presentation to Mike
to talk about why cloud
matters and why data analytics.
Mike.
MIKE LEONE: Thanks, Sap.
How's everybody doing?
Exciting first day?
So Enterprise Strategy Group
is an analyst and strategy firm
anchored in end user market
research and validation
services.
So we conduct annual
research throughout the year
across various
segments within IT.
And one of our most
popular surveys
is our IT spending
and tensions survey.
That's where we ask mid-market
and enterprise class
organizations where
they're placing their bets.
What are they
spending their money
on over the next
12 to 18 months?
And within that survey, we
track technology adoption,
challenges, pain
points, et cetera.
And obviously, one of the
major trends is around cloud.
And this year the surveys
show that 85% of organizations
are leveraging cloud computing
services to some degree.
Now of course, there are three
buckets of consuming cloud
computing services.
Software-as-a-service
is in the lead,
but the big takeaway here
is platform-as-a-service is
gaining traction.
Organizations are
starting to realize
the benefits of being able
to abstract the hardware
and focus on the data
and on the applications.
So with that in mind,
I'm sure many of you
have already migrated
to the cloud.
We leveraged our
research to understand
what are some of the advantages
of moving to the cloud.
And this is general.
This isn't specific
to analytics,
and far and away, it's
cost savings, right.
And of course, there's
a bunch of other items
that we can talk about.
Here are the additional
items-- flexibility,
accessibility, reliability,
manageability and whatnot.
But the big thing to think
about is all of these items
can come back to cost.
Accessibility, how is your
cost or revenue impacted
if there's downtime, there's
a failure with reliability?
OpEx is a big thing that
we're going to focus on.
So now let's shift to use cases.
Far and away, the major
use case right now
is lifting shift with
IaaS and PaaS consumers.
The next use case on
the list is leveraging
public cloud computing
services for analytics.
So think data warehousing,
data processing, BI, et cetera.
And I found that
really interesting.
The reason it's
interesting to me
is this was a more
popular use case
than leveraging the cloud
as a cold storage tier,
as a backup target
for archive, for DR.
So I thought that that
was pretty impressive.
And now let's talk a
little about spend.
What are mid-market and
enterprise organizations
spending on over the
next 12 to 18 months?
And the interesting
piece here is
there's an interesting
marriage, I think,
between these two items.
So over 50% of organizations
are going to spend more
on cloud computing services.
They're also going to spend
more on data analytics solutions
and becoming more data driven.
So when you put
the two together,
organizations aren't just going
to take out their checkbooks,
and say, yeah, I
need these things.
Everybody else is doing it.
I need to remain competitive.
They need to evaluate the costs.
And when you're evaluating cost,
especially going from on-prem
to the cloud, you need to think
about a little differently.
So I'm going to
share with you what
I think is a good high level
framework where you can start
to map out how
those costs differ,
specifically when
you're moving analytics
from on-prem to the cloud.
So the first bucket is
really traditional CapEx.
But to make it
fair for the cloud,
we have to account for if
you're leveraging a cloud
service where you're
paying an upfront cost.
So think of this
as a cost that you
have to pay before you're
starting to realize value.
So I bought the solution,
but it's sitting idle.
I'm still working on
configuring, deploying,
testing, et cetera.
The next, to really
account for the fact
that you're going to have
monthly costs associated
with consuming
cloud resources, we
have another category
around just cloud costs,
so month to month
costs associated
with storage, compute,
streaming, ingest, et cetera.
Now is where I think it gets
a little interesting when
we shift from CapEx to OpEx.
And this is really where
I feel the cloud shines.
So when we bucketize OpEx,
we do it in two ways.
First, it's just
traditional OpEx,
so that's time
and manpower spent
dealing with deployment,
configuration, procurement, et
cetera.
This isn't necessarily focused
on the actual application
or the data.
That's what the
next category's for,
which is around the
administration costs.
So a good way to think about
the administration cost--
obviously, I have
it here around what
you're doing on a daily basis.
But it's really more
about an IT administrator
and the amount of time they
spend responding to end users.
So if you're an
IT administrator,
and you're serving as a
gatekeeper to some degree--
the example here is around
query orchestration--
if you need to prevent
end users from accessing
the system in an
unlimited way, there's
a cost that's going to
be associated with that.
Finally, maybe the most
straightforward here,
maintenance costs.
So think support, professional
services, et cetera.
So to boil it up,
when we think TCO,
it really requires
a different frame
of thinking when
you're leveraging
the cloud for data analytics.
It's not just CapEx.
If anything, it's really
about understanding the OpEx
behind it.
So first and foremost,
you're really
overcoming those
traditional cost burdens.
You don't have to worry about
configuration, deployment.
over-provisioning resources
if you're leveraging the
right cloud platform.
And simplicity is a big
deal for a couple reasons.
First, it's about empowering
the IT generalist.
You don't really have to
worry about that skilled admin
dedicating a ton of their time
to deal with end user requests
when you're leveraging
the cloud platform,
and that simplicity
extends to the business.
If you have the right system
that's easy to use, intuitive,
you can really allow
the business analyst
to take matters into
their own hands,
in a controlled
environment, right.
We don't want to give
them access to everything.
And with that
simplicity, it actually
extends for the IT admin
around cost transparency,
visibility into what
those users are doing.
And that's a pretty
big deal, and it
yields some pretty
significant cost savings.
Now, the first three items
I talked about here, they're
obviously clear positives
for the cloud, right.
Yeah, great, we're going
to save a ton of money
going on the cloud.
There's going to be some
additional costs you have
to think about,
and one of those is
if you're leveraging
streaming applications.
When you're not necessarily
migrating in bulk,
but when you're
ingesting on a day
to day basis or a monthly basis,
you're going to incur costs.
The good news is
that they make tools
available to ensure that it's
reliable, highly available,
the workflows are
sustainable, et cetera.
So a lot of those items
can be quantified.
You can put a dollar value
down that's associated
with all those things.
Where organizations
tend not to look
is around the opportunity cost.
And there's a lot of
angles to opportunity cost,
but what I would say is, there's
so many organizations now
that are data organizations, if
not every organization's a data
organization.
They understand that data is
their most valuable asset.
They want to be
more data driven.
They want to leverage
a system that
can respond to the business in
real time or near real time.
And they want to make sure
that that system allows
for end users and IT admins to
do more for the organization.
They want everybody focusing
on that core business.
With that in mind, if
you're allowed or enabled
by the platform you're using to
let more end users, analysts,
leverage a system to
try and derive insight,
you're going to
increase collaboration
across the entire organization.
And that's a pretty big deal.
So with that in mind,
I'm going to shift back
to Sap, who is going to
talk about two use cases
that he mentioned earlier.
First, we're going to be
chatting about BigQuery.
SAPTARSHI MUKHERJEE:
Yeah, absolutely.
Thanks, Mike.
So let's make it real.
I think we talked about
some of the frameworks
to evaluate costs,
both CapEx and OpEx,
but we're going to look
at two specific use cases.
One is moving your data
warehouse to BigQuery.
Let's try to quantify
some of these benefits.
So how many of you are
aware of what's BigQuery?
Quick show of hands.
Wow.
We all love BigQuery.
It's a great product.
So BigQuery is Google Cloud's
native data warehouse system.
It's a serverless
data warehouse that
doesn't require you to
preconfigure nodes and clusters
or do capacity planning.
You can get your data in, write
SQL queries, get your answers.
It's very simple.
Let's keep it that way.
There are a lot of
benefits of BigQuery,
like it's highly durable,
and encrypted, secure.
It allows real time
streaming data analytics.
But we will try to see
how all of these benefits
play a role in terms of the TCO.
So this is BigQuery's
architecture.
So it's fundamentally
different from traditional data
warehouses in a way, that
BigQuery does decoupling
of storage and compute.
So what it means is when you
get your data inside BigQuery,
you can store your data in a
replicated, highly distributed,
and consistent storage system
with very high reliability
and durability.
And when you fire a query to
get an answer from your data,
only then, Google
dynamically previsions
compute infrastructure
to query the data
and get you the
insights that you need.
So your compute infrastructure,
which is very, very costly,
is not running all the time,
unlike many other cloud
based data warehousing system.
And then there
are other benefits
that we're going to talk
about in this context.
So the first thing is, in a
traditional data warehouse--
those of us who have
operated in traditional data
warehouse-- you typically
load your data overnight.
Next day morning, you will
get this management reports
based on the historical data.
You do a lot of BI and
descriptive analytics
on top of your data.
You use traditional ETL tools.
You have a DBA.
The person is doing
defragmentation on disk,
creating indexes, refactoring
some of the storage systems.
You need to be putting
a lot of operations
over it to make your
data warehouse responsive
and keep the data
warehouse up and running.
But BigQuery changes a lot
of those traditional mold
around data warehousing, right.
So we have automated
data delivery.
Unlike traditional
data warehouse,
and you own the data
warehouse on-premise,
you get like, an empty box.
And you need to spend three
months to get the data
warehouse up and running.
In some of the other
clouds also, what you get
is a bunch of
nodes and clusters,
where in BigQuery, we have
connectors for direct SaaS
application, like
AdWords and YouTube,
so you can immediately
start getting data
from those applications
directly into BigQuery.
BigQuery also lays the
foundation for AI, not just BI.
We do support a lot
of BI and reporting
on top of data stored in
BigQuery with the partner
tools like [INAUDIBLE] and
Tableaus of the world, and also
as well as with
Google Data Studio.
But we also support AI.
And TensorFlow has
direct connectivity.
You will hear some of
the newer announcements
we are going to
make in this area.
BigQuery also supports real
time streaming data on-site.
So that means you can actually
start streaming real time
data directly inside BigQuery
and start populating the data
warehouse with real time data.
And then a lot of
data operations,
there is no concept of
indexing, or essentially taking
backups, et cetera.
It's all of those data
operations steps have
been automated.
So if we have to translate all
of this and quantify, so what?
Does it impact my TCO?
It does.
And we actually had ESG, and
then ESG actually conducted
a study to understand if
BigQuery's architecturally
a very, very different
data warehouse,
how does it actually
impact customers' TCO?
So Mike, what were
some of the findings?
MIKE LEONE: Thanks, Sap.
So as Sap mentioned, we
conducted a three year TCO
analysis.
And we compared on-premises
Hadoop an Amazon Redshift
to Google BigQuery.
And one of the things
I want to call out,
very important to call out,
we looked at Amazon Redshift
reserved instance pricing
and we compared it
to BigQuery's on-demand pricing.
You're probably saying,
well, wait a minute.
That's not fair.
And really, one
of the reasons we
did that is because when
we were talking to some
of the customers, it ended
up that leveraging on-demand
was more cost effective
for them than leveraging
reserved instance.
Now I understand the
predictability side of it,
and that's fine, and everybody
can have their views.
So we took that
approach based on what
we were hearing from customers.
We leveraged end
user market research.
We leveraged publicly available
pricing, which is fantastic
about the cloud.
And then we did
qualitative interviews
with a number of Google
BigQuery customers,
to understand where they
were and where they are now.
What kind of pain
points did they
have with their
previous solution,
and what benefits
have they gained
since leveraging BigQuery?
And those customers came
from Hadoop to BigQuery.
They came from
Redshift to BigQuery.
They actually came from
Redshift back to on-prem,
back to BigQuery, which I
thought was pretty interesting.
So we took all that data,
and we created a model.
And that model was spread across
three different organizations
that we just kind of threw out
there as good starting points--
small, medium, and
large organization.
Now some of the
considerations when
you're looking at an
enterprise data warehouse,
we factored in, number of
data citizens, analysts
that are actually doing the
querying, how much data's
stored, how much data is queried
of the data that's stored,
and then factored in
streaming applications,
because you're going to
incur additional costs.
Now I know these three year
savings are pretty eye popping.
You don't really expect it.
So I can't just show
you the numbers.
I got to show you a little bit
what goes behind the numbers,
right.
So we actually went into--
I know this isn't [? iChart. ?]
This is one of many Sheets.
And this is really
boiling it up.
But the important takeaway
is, you know the buckets
I mentioned earlier?
We started with those
buckets, and then we
added line items, one
underneath, underneath,
underneath, and started
factoring in costs,
and taking all the information
that was available,
and applying it to the
three organizations
that we were modeling.
And one of the
takeaways here is,
while BigQuery
provided savings or was
at least equal to Redshift
in a number of cases,
where it really shined
was on the OpEx side.
So you can see here about,
I want to say, three
or four buckets
down, you're going
to see significant
savings on BigQuery.
So why is that?
Well, BigQuery markets itself
as a PaaS and it is a PaaS.
It's serverless.
You don't have to worry about
the infrastructure at all.
That takes a massive
amount of savings
out from Redshift,
which you still
have to manage some
of the infrastructure.
Now it's a perfectly fine
solution, and that's fine.
But when we look at
costs, you really
have to understand that you're
going to be spending time
spinning up instances,
and selecting instances,
and scaling up instances.
So the infrastructure
really is not abstracted.
That abstraction has a
major impact on savings.
So again, looking
back at the savings--
and I'll leave it up there for
a little longer this time--
first and foremost,
in the modeled
organizations-- and this
is important to reiterate.
That was for those three
modeled organizations.
There are going to
be organizations
that could potentially
have larger savings.
There could be
organizations that
may not have savings at all.
And that's fair, and
Google knows that.
We know that.
Everybody knows that.
But first and foremost, going
from on-prem to the cloud,
you're going to save money.
But what you're
going to see here
is the cloud provider that
you select really matters.
So if you're looking just at
this medium sized organization,
great, I can save $300,000
going to Redshift.
Well, I can save
another $1.7 million
over three years
going to BigQuery,
for again, this
modeled organization.
So the point here
is one, you really
need to understand your
costs to accurately model
your specific organization.
So some of the takeaways
from the validation first
on the infrastructure
side, with BigQuery,
you can leverage
on demand pricing,
so there's no upfront
investment, which is fantastic.
And then you really
don't have to worry
about over-provisioning
resources,
because they spin up
automatically, based
on the demand of the query.
Next on the OpEx side,
don't worry about sizing.
Don't worry about
maintenance, really empowering
that generalist to do more.
And finally, cloud costs.
A few things I
want to talk about.
First, simplified pricing.
It's all publicly available.
You can see it.
They pay for storage.
You pay for processed data,
and then you pay for streaming.
Now obviously,
that's for on-demand.
Flat rate pricing is probably
similar to a reserved instance
pricing.
We can ask Sap later, but
I believe that's true.
You don't have to worry
about scale and compute,
because it's done automatically.
And finally, the last piece.
How many people have had
issues with interoperability
when then they're deploying
a big data infrastructure?
Anyone?
OK, cool.
That would have
been embarrassing
if nobody raised their hand.
But for the most
part, Google handles
the interoperability side of
incorporating new technologies.
So you pretty much-- you
keep leveraging the platform.
You have no idea
that you're actually
leveraging the latest
and greatest technology,
because they take care of the
integration of that for you.
So with that mind, I'm going
to hand it over to Sap and Sam.
And Sam's going to share
some experiences he's had.
SAPTARSHI MUKHERJEE:
Thanks, Mike.
That's really helpful insight,
but let's make it real.
So we have Sam King, and Sam
is an engineering manager
in Nuna Health.
They're a startup based
out of San Francisco.
And do you want to quickly talk
about Nuna, what you guys do?
And then we can jump into
the specific topic of moving
data warehouse to BigQuery.
SAM KING: Yeah, so
Nuna as a company
tries to help folks understand
health data so that they
can make better decisions,
folks like the government
with Medicare and Medicaid,
as well as employer sponsored
health plans and
insurance plans.
SAPTARSHI MUKHERJEE: Great.
And then you are dealing
with a lot of data.
Every company is, no
exception, I'm sure.
So before you moved to BigQuery,
what was the on-premise system
that you were using?
SAM KING: Yeah, so
we pretty quickly
made the decision that we
wanted to be on the cloud.
But our previous solution
before we were on BigQuery,
we started out
with a open source
distributed query engine.
And this worked fine
to start out with,
but once we were scaling
up, we started running
into a lot of problems with it.
Queries that used to take
seconds started taking minutes.
There were a lot of errors
that we were encountering, even
with pretty small queries.
And also, in order to
deal with a lot of that,
we needed to over-provision
the cluster, which
resulted in a pretty high cost.
And as a result, we
knew that we would
be able to fix those
problems, but it
would have taken a lot of time.
So we started to look into
different alternatives.
SAPTARSHI MUKHERJEE:
And then eventually you
moved to BigQuery.
So can you please take us
through what was your decision
making criteria?
What were the process
that you followed?
SAM KING: Yeah, so at Nuna,
we're a data-driven company.
We try to put a lot of
discipline between all
of the decisions that we make.
And so for this one, we
put together a spreadsheet.
You can see a model
of it up there.
And you can see BigQuery
is on the right.
We also evaluated
BigQuery against a bunch
of other different solutions,
including hosted ones, as well
as self-hosted solutions,
similar to the status quo
solution that we have
on the far left there.
On each of the rows, you
can see a different thing
that we care about.
So you can see we really
care about stability,
and so that's weighted
as a critical feature.
And there are a bunch of
other ones that are listed.
And you might be
wondering why we
have some of these features
in a talk about cost.
And part of this is
expanding the notion
of what you think of as
total cost of ownership.
So when we talk about stability,
for us, that really is a cost
concern, because if we
miss our customer SLAs,
then we're not getting paid.
Same deal with things like
operational experience.
If we already know
how to do something,
then we don't need to invest
time and the human cost there
in order to learn
about a new technology.
And so we took all of these
things that we care about,
we weighted them, and
then we filled out,
how good is each of these
technologies in each
of these categories.
So you can see for our
status quo solution,
it actually rates good in terms
of operational experience,
because we already have
some experience using it.
We knew what the problems were.
Whereas with overall
stability, that
rated poor because
of all of the errors
that we were talking about.
The next thing that we did after
we filled out a draft of this
was reach out to a
bunch of other folks
throughout the company to
get their opinion on this,
so shared the spreadsheet.
We got folks, including the
BI teams, including the CTO,
including some non-technical
folks in the company who
primarily care about
cost, to comment
on each of these weightings,
on each of these values,
so that the company
as a whole could
come to an agreement in terms
of making this decision.
And that was one of the
most important parts
of this process,
because initially, there
was a lot of resistance in the
company to going multi-cloud.
But because the
decision process was
so collaborative
and transparent,
we were able to get the
buy-in that we needed.
And you can see at
the very bottom there,
there are some scores.
So we used the
sidebar on the right,
and we multiplied the weights
by each of the values,
summed it up to come
to those scores.
And then we did a
proof of concept
with BigQuery as well as
hosted solution number one.
And when we did that,
we found that BigQuery
was even easier than we
had predicted to prototype
and to get running, so we
switched over to using that.
SAPTARSHI MUKHERJEE: OK.
And Nuna deals with a
lot of health care data.
Like you mentioned, you are in
the business of health care, so
regulatory compliance
and security,
those are important
consideration.
How do you evaluate those
options in the cloud?
SAM KING: Yeah, absolutely.
At Nuna, because we deal
with health care data,
we have a saying, every
row of the data is a life.
And so privacy and
security for that data
is absolutely a top concern.
And for us, one of the
biggest features of BigQuery
and Google Cloud Platform when
we were making this decision
was projects within
Google Cloud Platform.
So a project is
basically full separation
of all of the resources,
including BigQuery,
as well as Google Cloud
Storage and any other service
that you use.
And at Nuna, we care a
lot about data separation,
because we need to keep
each of our clients' data
separate from one another.
With our other cloud, we had
to write a lot of custom code
in order to achieve that.
And that's pretty
expensive to maintain,
because not only if there
were a security breach
would that be very
costly, but the amount
of time that it takes
us to understand
all of multi-tenancy
support that we've
built in just to develop
those technologies
are pretty significant.
And so with BigQuery, we
just used separate projects,
and that works pretty
transparently for us.
And in addition to that,
it helps improve the cost
transparency and the cost
controls that we have.
SAPTARSHI MUKHERJEE: Right.
And what has been
experience thus far?
You have been in BigQuery
for couple of years now?
SAM KING: Yeah, we've
been using BigQuery
for a little over a year.
And so our experience
has been very positive.
Both in terms of human costs
as well as machine costs,
we've seen cost reductions
when moving to BigQuery.
From the human cost
perspective, if we
had stayed with that
open source technology,
we would have needed
to invest time
in improving the scalability,
reducing latency, reducing
error rates, and improving
multi-tenancy support.
And each of those things would
have taken multiple engineer
months.
And as a startup, we really
didn't have that time,
even if that were a
good use of human time.
And with BigQuery
on the other hand,
it only took us
a couple of weeks
to build out the infrastructure
and automation to switch over,
and another couple
of weeks to move over
our SQL to the new dialect.
And since then, it's
been pretty hands off.
So from a human perspective,
the costs have been much lower.
And then from a
machine perspective,
it's been an even bigger
win, since, as Sap mentioned
earlier, the separation between
storage and compute on BigQuery
has been big for
us, since we have
a lot of data that
we need to store
but that we don't
query very often.
And in addition to
that, we have a lot
of customers that need to have
access to all of their data
within a few seconds, but
they might only query it once
a week.
And so because of that,
we need to support
very bursty query patterns.
And BigQuery's been
great about that.
And the only way that
we were able to support
that with our open
source solution
was by dramatically
over-provisioning the cluster.
So switching to BigQuery
has reduced the cost for us
all around.
SAPTARSHI MUKHERJEE:
Great, great.
Thanks for sharing
the insights, Sam.
Thanks for coming over.
Really appreciate it.
Thank you.
So moving on.
Talking about the
use case too, I
think the neat summary from
the BigQuery conversation
is not all the data warehouses
that are running in the cloud
are the same.
We need to be really careful
to understand how those data
warehouses are designed,
how they are architected,
how it's going to
support your business,
your very specific use case,
your requirements, to come
to a TCO model.
The second one is moving
Hadoop and Spark to cloud.
Again, how many of you are using
some form of Hadoop or Spark
for data processing?
A lot of you.
Great.
We all love open source.
Google Cloud is
committed to innovate.
And while we
innovate, we're also
embracing the best of
the Apache open source
project for data processing.
Dataproc is a fully
managed service
that runs on our cloud for
Apache, Hadoop, and Spark.
We just announced the support
for Apache workflow for--
Apache Airflow for
workflow orchestrations.
But let's talk about
this particular use case.
So this is a typical
lifecycle of Hadoop
and Spark cluster
implementation, right.
So you first obtain the hardware
server, configure the server,
install the OSS, then go
through multiple iteration
of reconfiguration,
optimization, debugging,
and then finally
process the data.
It's a pretty labor
intensive process.
And we are working
with companies, really
large, planet-scale
internet companies
like Yahoos of the world.
Twitter just announced
that they are
going to move thousands
of Hadoop clusters
to Google Cloud.
We are working with
disruptive startups
who are very leanly
resourced but managing
a huge amount of data.
And then we are also working
with large enterprise
companies, like the Home
Depots of the world,
the HSBCs is of the
world, and they're
moving their big data processing
workloads to Google Cloud.
There is a reason behind it.
So when we get to
conversations with customers,
and we typically ask, so you're
using your Hadoop and Spark
solutions on-premise
or in some other cloud.
What are some of the core
challenges that you face?
I think scaling is a
major, major problem.
Especially with spiky workloads
with lot of seasonality
involved, where the data
volume could be unpredictable,
scaling often chokes
customer down,
because they have
pre-provisioned
capacity and expanding that is
going to take a lot of time.
Utilization, and
this is the flip side
of over-provisioning--
like if you
have to provision for
the most spiky workload,
then you end up creating on an
under-utilized infrastructure,
for you have to be
accountable to your CFO.
Hey, my resource utilization
is less than 20%.
Why should I keep continuing
this in my data center?
And then if you try to
optimize either of these two,
you encounter a
lot of cost pain.
Like if you keep changing
your cluster configuration,
you'll have to keep
re-provisioning your hardware
infrastructure.
There's a lot of cost
associated with it,
not only just hardware cost,
but professional services that
comes along with it.
So what Google Cloud
offers in this space
is Dataproc, which is a fully
managed Hadoop and Spark
service that allows you
to run Hadoop and Spark
jobs on our cloud.
And Dataproc is an
interesting service.
So there are a couple of options
for companies to run Hadoop
and Spark jobs on Google Cloud.
One is if you're
running it on-premise,
you pretty much do everything
for running a data processing
job.
You write custom code.
You do monitoring of the
health of the cluster, scaling,
job submission,
connectivity, deployment,
everything pretty much.
Then if you choose to move your
Hadoop and Spark job as a VM
option on GCE, Google Compute
Engine in Google Cloud,
you still do a
bit of automation.
Like connectivity,
deployment, creation,
those steps are taken
care of by Google Cloud,
but the rest of the thing, you
still have to do as a company.
And then when you move to
Dataproc, it's fully managed.
So almost the only
thing that you do
is just writing custom codes.
The rest of the things are
taken care of by the platform.
And by the way, small plug-in.
We're going to have a really
interesting announcement around
Dataproc on Wednesday--
that's tomorrow--
that I can't talk now.
I wish I could.
But we had ESG, and
they came again just
to prove the same point,
that not all Hadoop and Spark
managed services that
are running in the cloud
are the same.
So how is Dataproc
different from some
of the other alternates
that are out in the market?
And if a customer is already
running it in on-premise,
why should they even
bother to move to cloud?
So Mike, do you want to
share some of the insights
from that research?
MIKE LEONE: So when evaluating
TCO for Hadoop, Spark,
there's a couple of obvious
considerations, right, node
count.
How many nodes are you
going to have in a cluster?
What are your
resource requirements?
What's your workload demand?
Those are two pretty
obvious costs.
Now we start to get to
tricky areas, daily runtime.
Is your existing cluster running
24/7, or is there downtime?
And if there's downtime,
how much is it down?
Are you running batch
requests during evening hours
and then during the day, or
allowing for ad hoc querying
while you're doing
batch at the same time?
And with that in mind,
the ad hoc querying
starts factoring in that
IT administration time.
So is your IT administrator, or
are you, kind of a gatekeeper?
Or are you trying
to prevent analysts
from running ad hoc queries,
because they could potentially
disrupt batch queries that
are going on almost 24/7
to some degree?
So you really have to
factor in those costs,
and you have to understand
the types of runtimes
that your environment's
working with.
And finally, burst requirements.
Sap mentioned this.
You have to plan for
over-provisioning
when you're on-prem.
With a cloud, it's not
necessarily something
you have to think about,
because you can easily scale up.
You can easily scale down.
That elasticity that
the cloud provides
enables you to say to save
costs when there is downtime.
So we've leveraged the
same buckets as before,
but we broke it down
a little differently
to account for Hadoop
and Spark to some degree.
And we broke out
server and storage
separate, because
it's decoupled.
We also factored
in infrastructure.
Infrastructure here happens
to be specifically associated
with power cooling, floor
space, that kind of stuff.
And then, finally administration
and those cloud costs.
So takeaway away one,
you're going to save money,
regardless of the cloud provider
you use for the organization
that we modeled here.
Key takeaways, save
up to 70% or more
on the reduction in hardware.
That's a big savings.
OpEx side of things,
you could save up
to 85% going from
on-prem to the cloud,
based on what we modeled here.
And some of the key points
around EMR versus Dataproc,
in this case, you're going to
see similar areas of savings
that we saw with BigQuery around
administration, around cloud.
It's not as drastic, I would
say, as the BigQuery side,
but you're still going to
gain an economic advantage
by leveraging
BigQuery in this case.
Now the last piece I want to
mention is at the bottom here.
It's agility, and this goes
to the opportunity costs.
So when we were
talking to customers
and interviewing them
as part of this study,
these are quotes from
three different customers,
across three different
verticals, unrelated,
that I thought was interesting,
that, again, we can't quantify.
But there's definitely a
cost associated with it.
So first is around
being able to leverage
a platform that will allow you
to increase current revenue
streams.
If there's a business
demand for something,
you can easily access
it in the cloud,
and you can satisfy the
requirements of that workload.
Next is being able to
capitalize on a new opportunity
and being able to,
again, leverage
that scalable system
that can instantaneously
cater to your workload demands.
And finally, the
last piece-- and I
found this one interesting.
I've heard this
multiple times so far,
over the course of
the last two days,
from customers who
leverage not just Dataproc,
but a number of GCP services--
the ability to succeed, but
more importantly, fail faster.
And I want to go on
this for just a second.
If you're leveraging
a cloud service
and you're able
to provide access
to more people in
your organization,
you're going to obviously be
able to gain insights faster.
And with that in mind,
you'll understand
if you're going to be
able to continue down
the path of an initiative
you have, or you can just
stop and say, you
know what, this
isn't going to be successful.
Let's move on to the next one.
That is something that this
particular organization
was able to do multiple times.
And they really emphasized
the fail faster.
So with that in mind, I'm
going to shift back to Sap,
and he's going to highlight
a couple of other customers
that weren't part of
our study to highlight
a couple of other quantitative
or qualitative savings.
SAPTARSHI MUKHERJEE:
Thanks, Mike.
So just to kind of rephrase
some of these concepts
and make it real, we
took two examples, one,
a traditional enterprise, very
traditional, but really great
organization, Telegraph Group.
They run one of the
most popular newspapers
in UK, more than [? 19 ?]
million subscribers.
They were facing challenges to
understand customer sentiment
and do personalization,
because their existing systems
that they had for
their data warehouse
were not able to scale
for the type of analysis
that they are trying to do.
So what they did
was they at first
tried another cloud
hosted Hadoop offering,
just to see if they can
offload that particular part
of the workload and
run there, and continue
to run their on-premise
data warehouse system.
It was just not scalable.
The systems were not
talking to each other.
The cost was going
through the roof.
So they finally started
doing a POC with BigQuery
and then started using it.
Now Telegraph Media
is essentially
analyzing more than 4 terabyte
of data in less than a minute.
They minimized the
cost per query.
Look at how fine grained some
of these customers are going.
They're essentially trying to
track how many times the data
warehouse is getting
queried, what's
the volume of data that
is getting queried, what's
the cost per query.
And they are seeing
cost per query saving.
That's like the ultimate
realization of the value
from a data warehouse.
And then it reduces their
overall data analysis time
from hours to minutes.
And it's making the whole
organization much more
responsive.
They're able to launch campaigns
for their customers much more
responsively, rather than
waiting for days or weeks
for IT teams to get back
to them with results.
And then the other
example that we took
is a disruptive startup.
So Ocado is one of the largest
online retailers based out
of UK, and they are
redefining grocery experience
through online web and
mobile application.
And Ocado, you can
read about Ocado.
There are multiple
articles coming in
"Economist," like how they're
disrupting the whole industry.
They are one of our
BigQuery customers.
And Ocado is dealing with
massive, massive amount
of data, hundreds of
terabytes of data.
And they had two concerns.
One is scale, because they
are moving so fast, growing
so fast, they wanted the
data analytics infrastructure
to support that growth.
And the second thing
is, while they grow
and while they
become responsive,
they can't have unprecedented
cost exposure on their data
analytics side.
So they came to Google Cloud.
They're not only
just using BigQuery,
but they are using a
whole other set of tools,
using Dataproc, GCS.
And what they got is
one, query performance--
it improved dramatically
after moving to BigQuery, so
faster time to insight.
It increased their
contact center efficiency.
They're using not only our data
analytics stack, but machine
learning to do labeling for
emails, automatic responses
back to their customers.
And Mike talked about
opportunity cost.
This is how the company is
realizing opportunity cost,
by introducing inventory
churn, by being more responsive
and reaching out to
the customers on time
and saving lost sales.
And you have to start
quantifying those numbers
by factoring in
opportunity cost.
So we talked a lot
about different concepts
and frameworks,
gave you use cases.
We had Nuna.
We talked about customers.
So how do you take it
back home and start
applying for your businesses?
So a few things if
you have to remember--
I think to summarize--
I mean, we are having
a conversation right
before this presentation.
If I have to summarize this,
we call it TL;DR in Google,
Too Long; Do Read.
So basically, all that
glitters is not gold.
All the data warehouses
are running in the cloud
were not designed for cloud.
So if you are
evaluating options,
start thinking about a long
term horizon, not just what's
the upfront cost of
option A versus B.
It could be a one year, two
year, or three year horizon,
based on your cost appetite
and exposure appetite.
The second thing
is go beyond CapEx.
Just don't think about, OK, how
much I have already invested,
what's my sunk cost, what's my
CapEx going to be, and how much
my OpEx going to be.
It's not a CapEx
versus OpEx comparison.
We need to factor
in other costs.
Build a framework.
Nuna showed how
they went granular.
They built a framework
that was pretty exhaustive,
that actually was designed for
their specific business use
case.
So for your business, you have
to build your own framework.
Factor in business priorities.
Scope in data growth.
The amount of data that
you have in your system
is not going to remain the same
over the course of next two
or three years, and that's
going to be the number one
blocker for you to grow.
User consideration
and usage pattern.
How many users are BI user?
How many users are
doing ad hoc analysis?
How many of them are doing data
science or machine learning
workflows?
And go granular.
Specificity and granularity
is very important in cost
consideration.
And then consider
opportunity cost.
Like Ocado, for example,
or Telegraph Media,
they're all thinking about,
how is my data management
platform going to support
my business vision and goal?
And then compare cost
with next viable options.
Like hey, BigQuery cost
x amount of dollars.
It's just not enough.
If it is not BigQuery,
if it is Redshift
or if it is my
on-premise Hadoop system,
what are some of the next
viable options do you have?
And then do a comparative
study across those options
and then pick your best bet.
So with that, I
think we have come
to the conclusion of this
particular presentation.
I hope you got
something that's new.
We refreshed some
of the memories
for sure, like
taking about BigQuery
for those who are already
using it, or Dataproc.
We'll be here staying out
to take questions and have
conversations with you.
I really want to
thank Sam from Nuna
and then Mike from ESG
for their participation
and thank all of you
for your presence here.
Really appreciate it.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]